stéphane beyrouth marins pêcheurs vos
clés noires il installe son invention un
barrage anti sargasses à base de bambou
ici il présente un prototype pour
expliquer à la population son
fonctionnement
le barrage financé à 100% par la ville
du vauclin pourra être installés à des
endroits stratégiques où la profondeur
d'eau est faible ce type de barrage là
peut être planté entre 0 et 1 mètre
cinquante de profondeur
pour le moment il sera implanté à la
pointe fola pourquoi la bonne foule
avance que nous allons bel est décédé au
fond et on sait de la prostate et gic du
passage du barrage des sagas sicile
voeckler se trouve sur le niveau de la
poule à hopley en plaine est cent fois
ci c'est d'arrêter le sagace de laisser
passer les poissons les petits poissons
d'arrêter les agace et le diriger
une installation qui a attiré les
curieux qui n'ont pas hésité à poser des
questions et encourager l'enfant de la
commune
je pense que je souhaite que ça ici
parce que ça va nous donner
un petit plus au bout du chemin nous a
gardé son produit photo d'une petite mer
l'homme qui fabrique quelque chose on
avait discuté une fois mes enfants et
aujourd'hui ils maman il me manque
vraiment son oeuvre maintenant laisser
dans l'eau justement la mise à l'eau
devrait se faire dans les prochains mois
en 2019
stéphane bureau est en attente de fonds
pour passer à la phase expérimentale de
son barrage anti sargasses